the Joe Rogan experience it's the new
warriors have you seen the most the most
woke no what is it it's gonna look like
you don't think it's a joke really yeah
so this is the kind of thing he would be
laughing at okay and people cuz I
haven't read comics for like so I was a
kid
yeah movies but they should it should be
easier than ever to give kids the comics
okay what is this okay we have talked
about the snowflake can save space yeah
so this is really some kind of trolling
but basically they've been doing this in
comics for the last you know it's like a
nerdy he's having comics in like Star
Wars and all that [ __ ] was like nerdy
guys that don't get laid stuff at one
point and then it became kind of cool to
be a nerd and then it became a hot
property and soon ain't got cleaned by
like the low end the Cthulhu Portland
thing that's what the what comes of it
this on ironically look how ironically
they swapped the gender colors well
people mad and pink yeah people that are
[ __ ] I don't even know whose
jurisdiction this is but people were mad
at this the people that are trying to
pander to were like I don't dress like
this you better not it's ridiculous if
you dress like that even people that
don't want to make fun of you will start
making fun of you well it just looks
like I would give up I'm like I can't
mock you better than you're doing
yourself like what okay
I mean if I was gonna if I was like hey
why don't you make fun of the create the
stupidest whoa comic you could think of
that would be my characters throw her
balls is bigger than his balls to if you
noticed that well how do you know that's
the woman well I'm assuming the blue
with the hips like a woman is the woman
and the one that's built like a man I'm
assuming that's a man it's a trick
question the answer is piece of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] pig
you cisgendered ass [ __ ] yeah well wait
then here's well be negative isn't as
funniest oh wait where's the girl at the
back back that's the other one oh holy
same time goggles over his eyes because
he was exposed to his grandfather's
Internet gasps his grandfather's
experimental
it's really what's over it what was that
she's [ __ ] hot that's the old that's
the old Warriors the old ones in the
good days [ __ ] where's the girl with the
backpack what do you think her power is
her powers eaten cake know what it's a
magical backpack that has unlimited
snacks no I'm making that up she just
has a magical backpack oh my god a
pocket dimension with seemingly infinite
space which she could pull out useful or
random objects okay so look at the joy
so it's not always under her control
though she claims to get her power from
God but not the God you're thinking of
Jesus Christ I can't do this
but look at the joints let me see the
dry look her in the eyes well she looks
strong look she carry a lot of stuff on
her back what a magical it's too much
you can't be a superhero you eat too
much it's like you know how do I like
how Wendy from Wendy's got real big when
they showed her again this is like what
happened to Dora the Explorer she all
she got a whole turn
I gave one up they want something
they're like that's a true that's that's
that like that that's a luxury that's
like when you have the luxury of being
like like Gillette like are you good
enough to get Gillette as opposed to
being like please buy our thing weird
year we're a [ __ ] razor company
that's what this is [ __ ] you to the
people that are into that [ __ ] which you
can only do in a good economy like now
people but I love your [ __ ] you don't
get to just troll them right good porno
right it's gonna be harder to sell
things or I told me and make me laugh
like I will give it to that guy who made
that up
[Applause]